what makes the CDC so sure that it stops
with this one
individual well uh some of that of
course is the confidence the CDC has in
its own protocols and in public health
infrastructure in this country that's
what makes this so different from what's
happening in West Africa is that a place
like Dallas has the public health
infrastructure to try and uh to be in a
position to be able to isolate this
patient to be able to to trace the
people he came into contact with and to
be able to break it down from there uh
it's a level of confidence that uh not
every country in the world has but the
United States has in the public health
system and it's also to some extent Adam
of course an effort on the part of
federal officials to to try control some
uh any risk of Hysteria at this point
down in Dallas and Peter of course the
New York Times with the article on how
Nigeria is trying to be like the United
States with a better infrastructure the
mystery to me Peter Cook is which
airport did this guy come in through we
don't know that do we we don't know that
we don't know the carrier we don't know
if he uh uh stopped in multiple cities
on the way but the CDC director Tom says
that doesn't matter and the reason it
doesn't matter is because he didn't show
any symptoms uh even before he got on
the plane or when he got off the plane
he actually had his temperature taken
before he boarded the plane we did learn
that detail and he had no temperature
and so the fact that he wasn't
displaying any symptoms during the
course of the flight at least according
to the CDC that suggests that no one on
board that flight no one in any of the
air uh airports where he may have
traveled through uh faces any risk of
exposure at this point it wasn't until 4
days after he arrived in Dallas that he
first started showing uh symptoms uh the
one real question mark Tom is about the
moment he walked into the ER uh on I
believe it was the uh the 26th and it
was complained of symptoms that he
didn't feel well apparently at that
point it's not clear but nobody may have
asked him at that time if he'd been
traveling to uh to Africa or of course
if there was any risk that he was
suffering from Ebola of course two days
later he came back in a h in an
ambulance Adam to that hospital yeah
Peter uh just briefly I recognize you
were in Washington uh this palent is uh
patients in Dallas but um any angst
concern Etc in Dallas I know I would be
scared if I were in Dallas it's just
kind of human reaction obviously
obviously it's a huge Story down in
Dallas but there's one factor here
that's worth considering one of those
doctors who was initially came down with
hiola one of those American doctors Kent
brand
is from the Dallas area that Community
has followed his case very very
carefully and has seeing an American
come down with ebola and survive and
live to tell the tale I think that's
important I've heard from some folks
down in Dallas that that's made a big
difference to people in the community
they followed his case so carefully they
know you can survive Ebola and that
again the risk if you weren't exposed to
this person in uh in a direct fashion uh
little risk if any uh to anyone else in
the Dallas area Okay understood hey
Peter thanks for that perspective